the next quiz Rock not evil David
Copperfield there's a lot of Easter eggs
a lot of things planted in the show
especially for die-hard fans of the
original series is there anything we
should be looking out for in your
episode yes well there's something in my
episode I don't know if I'm allowed to
say there is a puppet that you should
keep an eye out for in the background
and a scene that I'm in a very famous
puppet I think the puppet is worth like
a million dollars or something like that
well you know who owns that puppet CBF
look it up CBS does not own that puppet
you you have to look the Rod Serling
family no David Copperfield oh I have to
get it from David Copperfield I think
they wanted you to something that stands
on its own but there were some deals
there to make with David Copperfield to
be allowed to use that puppet so there
were some interesting conversations
around that you'll have to decide what
really matters to him when the laughter
stops and how much he's willing to give
to the twilight zone you know with these
Twilight Zone episodes there's always be
a hidden message right something like
the audience takes away from it
what's that message in your episode I
think there are two messages one you
have to understand what you're willing
to do for success how much of yourself
are you willing to give up and and
that's the other thing is like for
success how much of yourself are you
willing to give up and until you have
nothing left don't wonder how much of
your episode specifically resonated with
you because you are a comedian and have
probably gone through some of the things
that happen in this episode uh yeah no I
really soon as he told me the promise I
was like that's something I think about
all the time you know it doesn't there's
a sort of a social media aspect to it
not only do I get on stage I trying to
be less active on social media but I've
been very active and and sort of the
effects that that have on you it just
really resonated with me immediately
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]